Dave I heard you say in an interview  this was an emotional journey for you  this movie and then I thought it's lego  ninjago but I don't want to I want to  believe you on this it's true it's true  the first time Justin and I got in the  recording booth I we were doing this  very intimate father-son scene and I  found myself crying thanks use me good  yeah good common for a boys crack I'm  still I'm still living through it  thriving that controllably yeah and kind  of like crying harder than I do in a  movie where I play a recovering heroin  addicts yeah and then we finished the  scene and I kind of took a step back and  evaluated the room and it was some  interesting energy and I realized I was  playing a green ninja Lego piece and I  needs to reel it in a bit  [Applause]  you